on this episode we talk about Donald
Trump user-generated content and I
answer to - Steve - video questions
[Music]
[Music]
Carrie be
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode one 11111
I'm the ask Gary Vee uh I'm fired guys I
don't know if you know this but I'm in
complete belief that this show is now
completely ripping on fire the Instagram
hustle that I've been putting together
Iraq do some editing is clearly working
enormous amounts of new fans to the show
I'm very excited about the momentum the
Facebook stuff the podcast push has been
intense India over the last several days
that's been fun if you're not subscribed
to the podcast
Android iPhone then you're making a huge
mistake
because you can listen to the show on
the run also before I get into the show
there's something really interesting
happening with the people that are
watching on Facebook a lot of you
haven't fanned me up on Facebook so do
that too a lot of right hooks on episode
111 really interesting thing the Iraq
show this screen now I love this
vaynernation I love that people one of
the things that I've noticed that has
brought a lot of awareness for this show
is the word of mouth which I so
appreciate from some of you but this
little hack and we saw it starting
Katniss is really just a social media
tidbit this started happening on
Instagram because there wasn't an easy
way to communicate Instagram and share
stuff so people started tagging each
other in the comments and we've seen a
growth inside of Facebook across up all
of a noir media of people now seeing a
post and just tagging their friend in
the comments because the alert system so
strong and so I just want to give a huge
shout out to everybody who is leaving a
comment with somebody's you know name in
there because they're passing on the
show and obviously that is social media
social media is the plumbing of
word-of-mouth in our society that is the
ultimate compliment that I get from you
watching the show so I appreciate you so
much and and that's that and so India
let's
get into the shell cool
Avinash asks what are your thoughts on
using curated content I'm a great
question you know it's funny I'm not a
big user of curated content at all and
UGC user-generated content is a thing
that a lot of brands at Vayner have
played with you mentioned guy-guy has
has done a ton of that you know I think
it's a it's a very smart tactic as a
matter of fact I think that I've not
done a good job in using it my biggest
problem with user-generated content is
the same reason that I don't give quotes
to other authors even though I get
bombarded every week of can you give me
a quote if I'm gonna give you a quote to
your book friend I need to read it I
don't read books
I don't time to read those books and the
reason I've the Reta is if you say
something stupid in chapter 17 and
there's so many people saying so many
stupid things about business and
marketing and social that I'm scared to
give my name on it because then I'm
endorsing you but then you're saying
like here's the way to hack Twitter and
it's wrong or here's my point of view on
Pinterest or it's wrong or here's have
to manage people and it's wrong I'm I'm
not on the same side there's a lot of
people on a lot of things it's just the
way it is and that doesn't allow me to
do that it's the same reason usually
generated content scares me because I
feel that if I'm curating it I'm
endorsing it and who has time to go down
the rabbit hole this is why would so
many of you hit me up and say I want to
you know just got it I got a spammy ass
email I almost sent to you and I was
like forget it it's just like it was
like so ridiculous it's like Gary can
you give me an hour of your time to do
this simulcast which I didn't go down
her rabbit hole but I think she's
charging for and like she had this whole
thing and said what's in it for you and
it's like you get side by side of 19
other marketers that she's also
arbitrage the whole thing was so
gangster I don't know she's a lot of
bull going on next question India that
had nothing to do with the question at
the end of just be ranting of how pissed
I am but my point was that she's user
generating content some of the memes she
had on there like I flat-out knew were
like people that are like a lowest
common denominator ebook stuff like and
just like I don't want to be
associated with that crap and like to
have you like first of all she seemed
like crap but like if she wasn't did she
know they were crap like I don't know
people just not doing their homework
India I never did my homework in school
but I definitely do it in business and I
know that was black and white cuz that's
how we roll
alright India let's go are you into spam
yes no no no I mean you think you think
it's a funny turn yeah I don't even know
what normal spammy ass is got it and
some people none designers in here we
clearly described me asked garbage pail
kid like that's what I need gets back to
make me a spammy ass garbage pail like
t-shirt they'll be coming soon alright
let's get back into color we're black
and white almost the whole show James
asks should I be writing unique content
on LinkedIn and medium or is it okay to
repurpose the content I've already
published on my blog James I'm a
believer in both the truth is we've been
testing both as as a team I do think I
think you can use specifically medium
and Linkedin I feel very comfortable in
cross pollinating because I do think
that there's some intellectual above the
brow kind of similarities on medium and
Linkedin
so those are very comfortably if you
said medium and snapchat the same
one-minute video I'd feel uncomfortable
because I think the context of the room
is different I think medium and Linkedin
are similar so if you feel like your
audiences and the context of the room
the vibe when you go into it are similar
then I think you can get away with it
and so we look at Facebook and and
LinkedIn and medium having similarities
but you guys see what I'm doing on
snapchat if you're not following me put
up the QR code d-roc a lot of editing
here today you'll be here late on a
Friday no [ __ ] half-day Fridays for
you d-roc anyway um you know I'm not
gonna do the same stuff on snapchat that
I'm doing and I'm trying to do different
stuff but medium and Linkedin I feel
fine with that now I think the open I
think we're doing it cuz we're busy as
crap and we're pumping out a ton of
content you're different than me the
people are watching or different than me
if you have the time I think it's
amazing if you could start the FIR
article with two or three different
lines in the first sentence that maybe
even acknowledged of like I'd love to do
in Livia this is maybe something we
should be doing I'd love to start doing
more stuff that's kind of like that
start that 99% of the articles the same
but maybe the first two centers or
something somewhere like you know I've
been seeing a lot of people on LinkedIn
do blank like all of a sudden you make
it very contextual if you're doing it in
LinkedIn or a common trend that we're
seeing on medium is blank that's why I
believe like there there's some
interesting contextual things you could
do up front that an extra sentence or
two change makes it even more native so
that's something to consider cool India
you're Brad hold on
get in here charity look at these cherry
you know what I know you're in black and
white now or d-roc go color for a second
so we can get the plunge Gary don't
worry just a time all right good
that hurt sorry suck it up this show biz
baby
yo bro opportunity to ask a question to
ask a ruby show this is amazing Gary who
follow a [ __ ]
hey Gary it's my co Sadiq aka @m show
liquor from Germany just got a quick
question I just saw that my new YouTube
channel and block and I'm putting out
content in German and English how would
you manage multilingual content in
social media thanks for your answer do
it again the wink is amazing
do it again cuz I really enjoyed it the
other beginning I didn't fully get not
easá an amazing amazing video Big Ups to
you I'm glad to give you some exposure
in here make sure you leave a comment in
facebook as well to like get more fans
out of this cuz clearly you've got a
nice buzz going not buzz like alcohol
like I mean like that was like not buzz
like I drink wine all the time when
you're not looking
I mean I mean uh buzzes like you got
some good energy look I think I think
you know how to handle this better than
I do there's certain questions that come
along in the show that the truth is I'm
not a practitioner in I haven't managed
I mean our brands have and I would say
the one thing that I would think a lot
about is if you're handling them in two
languages really use the capabilities of
Facebook specifically then allow you to
only target people that are you know
German speaking with the content and
then only English speaking huge
opportunity there obviously English is a
universal language in a lot of places at
this point so there's something to think
about there but I think it's the
targeting capabilities in with Instagram
getting Facebook's targeting
capabilities late this year I think
you'll have a chance where you're able
to segment properly and plan where your
contents going by language and region I
think that's super important so I would
say that I would say that a a
it's the organized planning upfront of
the distribution of the content that you
have more flexibility around in today's
world that you should take full
advantage of there's a lot of platforms
that you can't Pinterest Twitter things
of that nature and there I think you're
just you're doing your thing I've seen a
ton of people manage both I'm a big fan
of something with brands here talk
called Spanglish you know which is
expanding glish I'm a very and very
intrigued by some of the work we've done
for Latino brands where we start a
sentence in a tweet in Spanish and then
finish it in English have you tried the
German English play yet where you
actually are putting out content that
has both languages in it in the post and
the copy hack a little bit there I think
I just gave a lot of people a good
little nugget there I think that will
work I think you'll see a real
over-indexing opportunity there
especially with the youth who are
playing in both languages and who grew
up who grew up in households where like
I did with Russian English you start a
sentence in Russian and you finish it in
English that's how a bilingual works and
I think you should play with that are
you guys chatting with each other doing
the show you both you're both smiling at
the same time she's fine Ricky are you
laughs because I always use Ricky
like Ricky says here he is we've been
waiting for Ricky for years Ricky asks
what are you to sense about the Donald
running for president Oh India you know
I don't like political questions I'm you
snuck that in I got caught for not
previa mad of time what do I think I
think this is America and everybody who
wants to run should run I'm very
intrigued by the story that's come out
about him hiring actors to be at his pep
rally I thought that was funny
mainly because I was blown away that
somebody would actually do it for $50
for the whole thing all day said clearly
I don't because I think you can go to
Goodwill for two hours buy stuff and
sell it on eBay and make more than 50
bucks take that all you actors there's a
hack for you I think that uh I think
that uh I think he says a lot of
outlandish stuff I think that America is
more divided than ever on the left and
right because people are self selecting
what they want to listen to now because
you do have Fox and CNN you have the
Internet where you can go to very left
and right places and I think it's an
intriguing thing that's happening in
general in social media right now which
is I'm very concerned that people are
not getting rounded scenarios to the
world because it's so easy for you to
just go directly into what you believe
and you're having a very intriguing
thing happen in college where people are
seeing who the roommates are on Facebook
before they go now figuring out who they
are and then kind of asking out and
pairing up with like um a hipster and I
want a room with a hipster I've always
been very proud of myself in doing
controversial things like for example in
the height of post 9/11 going online
scared that I was going to Al Jazeera's
website to watch the screen because I
was like am I being because I already
knew we I was being watched before
everybody knew they were being watched
and like I hope they're not mad at this
because I really do you know don't
forget I'm a child of a Soviet family
whose mother wrote a book report that
Fidel Castro was the bravest man in the
world and believed it in her heart and
soul that this little country right next
to this bad empire America and then I
grew up in America and so like there's
always different perspectives I think
Donald will absolutely resonate with a
small segment of people in on the right
side
I'd be flabbergasted if he won the
nomination but I think my intuition
net-net
is Donald has the capability of
surfacing a conversation during this
process that could be healthy and I do
believe that anybody to the extremes of
anything have that potential and I'm
hoping that weirdly that gets people
more reminds people were more aligned
than were then we're different than
right now it's really intense in u.s.
politics in my opinion on how separated
we are and so my hope as an optimist
because that's who I am
he brings a singular issue during his
short run because I don't see him
winning the nomination that we could
that may actually bring value to the
conversation I'm intrigued by that
potential probably more than anything
that was a pretty it was a way better
answer than I thought it was coming
smack some things at Citi like that we
haven't showed send the intern yet just
just show him showed you Ricky
in the upper the right right I always
but when I was actually answering Ricky
I barely said Ricky Ricky Ted Rubin here
at Ted Rubin on Twitter and Gary the
question I have for you is about all
this talk you've had about
self-awareness lately and I love the
idea of understanding what our talents
are and what they're not but my fear is
that we're gonna get into a mindset of
things we can and can't do Robert
Browning says a man's reach you to see
this grasp
I want people to think that they can try
and do a lot of different things and I'm
afraid you'll bleed to our children and
make them start saying what they're good
at and not what they're not good at let
me know how you feel about that how you
can incorporate that into your
self-awareness talk
Ted big ups to you first and foremost
you've been you know again again back to
the theme of the show not digging fully
deep I'm not completely sure but it's
been really fun to watch from afar of
you amassing an audience and people
really respect you and kudos do your
thing I think it's a great question and
a challenging one he first and foremost
here's the way I answer this nothing
completely one way or the other is ever
healthy you should always be pulling
from directions finding a blend I will
say that I think people are way more at
this point James
20:15 in belief that they can do
anything are good at everything should
try everything should work on their
weaknesses so I believe that I'm being
aggressive and starting a conversation
that lends itself to like drawing a line
in the sand of strengths and weaknesses
that I think is very small I do not
believe this is a big conversation I
believe modern parenting is like hey
little Steve you can do anything you
want Steve sucks a basketball can't do
everything he wants and the amount of
people that want to play basketball for
a living or sing or want to be an
engineer you know like entrepreneur I
mean you know how I feel about that so I
think that um Ted I think you're right I
think right at this moment my point of
view on this is so small compared to the
overall conversation that I'm going 100%
all in and I don't want to hedge against
it with your point which is correct
because I think the whole markets
hedging against it and thus I'm just
trying to crackle it's the same way I
talk about social media marketing versus
traditional TV I believe in TV but I
don't need to advocate for TV 99% of the
markets advocating for TV I believe that
the market ninety percent of the market
is advocating for you can do whatever
you want you should try to do everything
else you should push yourself they
package it and you should try new things
and push yourself I don't think people
are talking enough about be very
self-aware know what you're good at
force yourself guys what I don't know if
you've broken this down do you know what
forcing yourself to be self-aware do you
know what that process entails drinking
a shitload of humble kool-aid uh-huh
like like it's insane of how much like
it's why I talk about liking to lose
like like it's insane of how much
humility I've had to instill
to now make it optically look like I
have too much ego and and self esteem so
many of you the first time you consume
me some of you like I'm really getting
in my face book mentions there's a lot
of you've noticed plenty of people
sharing my stuff and their friends are
saying screw this guy ego for days full
of himself I get it but what it actually
and what it actually is is the post-game
of me being really humble every minute
of my life to recognize what I should
stay away from and I think people have
not gotten into that gear so Ted I would
say
that um I get it and I agree with you
and everything should have a push in a
poll I just think the market is way way
in the direction of and I think that we
need a hell of a more line of life you
kind of suck at that you may want to
focus on that now if you love that then
do it but you need to know what that
comes along with which is if you love
singing more than breathing cool but
you're gonna wait tables and you're
gonna make eight bucks and that's great
because guess what I pay the price for
doing what I love in a lot of different
ways and so that's just life that's just
life cool question of the day what are
you doing this weekend I'm asking this
specifically because I know this is
gonna air later on Friday night and I'm
curious to see get everybody in there
get everybody in there to try to quickly
answer I appreciate you guys I'm really
enjoying the show I'm really really
enjoying the show this has really really
been enjoyable your engagement your
comments are really feeding me and as
it's happening more I'm feeling more
hype and so I appreciate you you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
ready you don't yeah your speakers are
fine it's me Gary here's the podcast
bonus question
[Music]